start with the emergency evacuation
announcement in the event of fire or
other emergency please exit the building
in an orderly manner to the assembly
point which is located in the market
carpark the fire exit in this room is
indicated by bring forest inside please
do not delay the evacuation by
collecting any belongings do not use the
list the premises was not really a far
greater than the all-clear please note
it is against the law to grab these
premises and this meeting please note
will be audio recorded that we have any
ice and one for disruption how to dry
being substituted by countless awards
them through any other
long mint of the 10-day mini it's
amazing how about 6 of december 2016 the
way and having to reload group rate any
declarations of interest
any questions on notice
item 6 motions on notice
item seven external need to report
certification of claim and returns
annual report 2015-16 they'd consider
the report for the section 151 officer
drawing members attention to the grant
claim and return specifications 2015 so
one we brought from the council which
terminal two terms 2015 16 b 1 and that
we know we know about thursday i
immediately pass this to my colleague on
the right this is chris hewitt foremost
announcer welcome and i've been a
cottage christmas complete the work and
sugar to explain it fully and then we
can answer questions as we go through
thank you good evening I'll just give a
bit my backgrounds of reports and just
good cover the main issues product
without going into the detail offering
for sale and steck machine afterwards
2015-16 the council prepared a claim
form for housing benefits the volume 17
very 18 million pounds so you could we
go to record that the claim to come from
the government
we got to have benefit expenditure in
line regards to the dignity we certify
that gun playing private land searches
of member which we which we and achieved
dwp in its work sets out a what work has
to be and that includes testing a series
of cases to the number of cases of 20 20
cases across three three areas and then
it's different areas in those cases we
have to be next 40 cases on errors that
we find that was the background to leave
the pause itself the report summarizes
the results of a certification work with
the key detail seeing on pages and 7.7
7.8 in your pack they're just detail and
the new errors that we found the work
undertaken this year and our full of
those errors that were found by the
previous audits his video in the
previous year the key messages are is
that we from the work that we undertake
on the took is that we didn't identify
the areas that required an amendment to
the grad claim this year we did report
on one error in our qualification
latitude department working pensions
which we averted whether i only had two
extra extrapolate for the error that we
found that was to ascertain three
thousand pound extrapolation and we're
waiting for the department of work and
patience to provide report to us or to
come back to council to say what further
actually wants a good doing the case
which is the normal course event and
from the work that we overtook we've
identified several areas for next year
where we were going to see us the
council still early work to do early
testing on extended testing of 40 cases
that will learn that will help in
advancing the word that we have to do
next year the finalists show up to
colleges is the fee on page seven point
nine this this is quite loan for
District Council and the reason for this
is the work that's done by internal
audit from doing the initial testing of
those 20 cases i mentioned earlier on
our behalf and we then we perform an
element of those to me check that we
agree with the concluding to the loss of
reached by doing that work that helps
keep the feet low and for next year that
will read the fee again is in the region
take eight a half thousand pounds so
that's the key messages from the claims
from having second questions there any
question yes thank you so just let many
of adjustments which you found an error
can you just explain what the why manual
adjustments are needed what's under and
what country they might be in front of
the month or a year it's the manual I'm
sorry Paige 7.7 with then refers to an
recommendations of 1415 their findings
in 1516 when there were no errors in the
flat reviewing but is just referred to
many adjustments way from the monthly
basis to confirm accuracy of input the
numbers wondering what the what the
manor guess was might be for why they
are needed to be made and how have
common is it amongst district councils
and for many investors to be made is it
because the calculations are quite right
i assume is not just inputting blanket
or a few misses a manual adjustment to
provide little tickets at the figure
provided yes there are two the series's
my manual adjustments connect can occur
it is a common factor
in counseling we come across and it is
something that we check back at that
councils the first one is where in
during during me in the system sometimes
systems that we coddle or informations
is required under and sexily council
officers do repair and co-op with that
is a bunion since last we made and we
can the list of those are kept by the
council which we then able to check
that's a seminole war council
deliciously love it's awesome here we
look at and I think also the there is
one element of an errand that we found
where by the think that the excellent
start date for a claim have been just
thought of a reason and we can pick that
up from the system or not checking that
data that I also revealed an error for
these these are common issues that we
find in our councils you say that you
that we as a council keep a record of
the claim you check that a record of the
menu adjustment and you check those if
there was no recollected many respondent
you know that there had been a menu
adjustment there is all that come out in
another party with protection on stuff
on the Santa vs saints well the it's
good question nothing really the issue
is that okay and the council has systems
in place to recall those those justices
he happened to have no good sees you
have light in those systems we have made
almost every review gets renewed the
controls that were there to do that
thank you you happy lives I think I
guess fabienne together
thank you water you have an army efforts
and one else got any other questions
prevent the recommendation it proposes
20 results of the certification of
flames and return angry for 2015-16 be
noted that rate right item 8 2016 17
external audit audit plan thoughts and
that's to consider the report of effect
in 151 officer dissenting the council's
external auditors annual audit plan
covering the audit of the 1617 accounts
and certifications claimed and return
again again Thank You chair and again
old hot ex Chris this is to external
plan we have reviews in concord and
approved from i want you to ask again
Christopher let's say importance coach
inspecting yes this for big plan then
check out our proposed work for in
2016-17 or the appropriate the financial
statements and our arrangements that to
look at the council's arranged at
surviving for money and the key elements
of the plan are on section 2 which are
it on page eight points have nothing
this sets out the key risk areas again
that these these three this year our
standard to most of us councils and the
first to represent where there's the
scope maybe for management to manipulate
controls we have no evidence of this
rochford so it's like they're not clear
to start
but I also be okay but it is our
auditing standards which directors into
these areas so I'll it says that we have
to stop the test these areas and agility
to check though no recent appears and so
these include the review of revenue and
particularly to check whether and
expenditures not being capitalized when
it should actually learning you and the
second area is large mantova right of
controls itself where we test journal
entries of became estimates look unusual
transactions through our testing and
retesting raviolis so these are standard
we've been all the clans and a lots of
particularly to torture himself the
third area are just abandoned other risk
that we're addressing this year and this
is this arises because citra house
specified its current practical on
campus on government a new presentation
and income and expenditure in financial
statements and it's quite a large change
and Stepford and ourselves of guilty
wife giving national training all those
two local councils and we'll be taking
an early few words that often would you
spot a fine I've seen two to have their
first look at this presentational change
so we can give an early opinion on it
before the for the financial stakes are
produced the second next section without
can ID Italian ages hence Cullen's it's
just clarified what that actually means
and cooking member tilla equally
accounts year-on-year actually quite
complex terrain to the income and
expenditure statement and even from my
phone you looking
how does that relate so information
detailing throughout the year on you
think like gear out turn an expenditure
that was never really there was a link
clearly because the numbers whatever
them so many accounting entries in there
actually you could never allow it to
it's quite difficult to go so what's it
for and I've agreed now is that we will
start to think about help so the same
way we present the au turn and the
budget report to Council that's the same
way now that the accounts will be
presented to the top part will be as you
expected to see it in our net budget is
10 million and then underneath that you
see will be accounting entries in turn
out that will then get us what we call
our income expense to life so it took
quite a very visual way to be able to
say okay I understood that we told that
all the way through the year I can
understand that and then you can see the
accounting entries and getting to that
was previously previous years it's all
been a mixed into actually quite complex
it almost certainly was done that way to
BSN it's absolutely so by then we ruined
in this thing called circle is actually
made life a lot easier for our
accountant interest and a lot easier to
explain as well so we're hoping
something quite positive team classes
also the early work with Eli if this
sort of test our approach to make sure
we we've got quite well will they learn
in make sure we fit the rules on before
the actual closing again oh yeah I just
like it thanks the listing of the
continent it's actually less for us
though so this to be honest we better
yes so that next section is on section 3
which to do with the valley for money
conclusion there we have two significant
risks that we reaffirm raised in that
which one will be publishing our work on
this year normally work one is the theme
that we we looked at last year which
called as a financial position of the of
the authority and in that topic of
record is the project gathered three
point and finally much when 2020 well
that's before that
plan was drafted I believe that that
figure will now be 2.1 million lafayette
and again it's a question that will do
the same word of his last year look at
we sorta soldiers behind the budget and
the counsels approach in maintaining
services looking performance measures as
well in terms of health other councils
performed in terms of the financial
difficulties in see it is addressing and
saving plan that concepts of your place
swell account how it was those are and
the second element there is to do with
the local authority trading company that
these butchers are established and there
are folks really easily shared on
governance arrangements and salves and
justify ourselves of them in terms of
the advice that they become something
sensible before me and the Rangers have
a look in skills are we use to others
any issues that we need to be aware of
one can consider just the three further
elements that just need clawed your
attention are the paragraph on
materiality April 13 where we set out
what level is material to work through
it was spending time that can change
because when we get the final accounts
we update a materiality level before the
final get to you and our all it was also
calls at the end of the year and at
eight point 15 and 16 as though
independence issues that i need to draw
to your attention and at eight point 17
the early phase 37,000 657 although on
that there may be in terms are only with
some some extra fee may be involved and
the on the net and that's where we have
to do
looking at them and you presentational
rain in this form of the accounts be
right up those are the key items on from
your lip balm so question on the Thunder
hey I Cancellara thank you I'm focused
I'm putting too much I'm just going to
say two words and then carry on my know
what I refer to these instead then but I
can refer to the words project wyvern
and it's in relation because a in the
public domain and I just leave any for
money risks we will you and have you
access to the exact papers for that and
will that form part of your your value
for money risk because obviously that
would in the medium term from part of
the not savings as such but possibly
income generation to close the game I
don't expect you to go into detail
please extent but I sort of like I'm
standing you're aware of it and we
really not departed what you're doing
yes we are not wearing have discussions
would be and the Thank You director Rob
as well so in those general terms i'm
aware of the project we are actually
have access to all reports that's our
issue by the council one can request at
exempt reports and in terms of looking
at saving concepts if that's part of it
and then that's does things will be
aware of them taking them to thank you
that was the question okay
cats in origin point I 12 News's
theorists my excuse the specialists is
that they are always going to be
expensive there's no inflation obviously
they anticipated extended to really
understand that but if they're a little
at which he would come back to us to get
approval for use of specialists if it in
terms of statistics that are are
highlighted in the report these again
will be all at all auto plants or let's
go consumed in all other times these are
normal course of events specialists that
we use in terms of the pensions the pw
speed we are always obvious engages
people we see to review and if the actor
is used by councils and our pensions
team if you that before but i can you
see this is all current in the audit
thing so there's no where the cost of
the council and our basis is the same on
the property plant equipment the
difference is if we do find an error in
the accounts and that's ever procedures
that we would have to absorb up through
extra specialist work in that instance
there will be an extra fee and we have
to discuss some of the duck sexual
problems one officer in the first
instance and i said to clarify light
your fees at the moment would you need
up on any mistakes cover the users of
mystery arts graduate till you're happy
with us again
it's just just a bit of the question
being relatively new to this I notice
the expression entity wide control now
again succeed based programming in your
accounting system the titanium n if the
peasant money goes through this
unfortunate of certain way and there's
an entry that you can actually track
that as part of the larger sum as a way
to tease like your eminency desolace
buildings and sort of is that how that
the work that partly improvement will we
now have enabled being able to perhaps
follow an expenditure through system
better which could be bits and pieces
all over the later we can we should be
able to do that anyway so any good
financial system should get to do their
best as you can so any money that comes
into the council imminent comes into the
organization we track it and then we
know exactly where it's going to go and
obviously any movements that are outside
of the system are called the journal and
that would be run by Matt and team and
actually there's a lot for those we know
exactly where it's gone unwise gone
there as well so yes absolutely whether
that's what that means in this context
I'm not entirely sure what this was an
important right entity level controls in
an terms means we're talking basically
have the whole control that the council
has in place generally if the counselors
can cover it's a wide-ranging term that
we look at in terms of our playing
dealing with for instance risk
management's she human resources as the
controls other why the scale the council
house that we take note of in terms of
deciding whether that the overall
control environment ease is sound or not
or whether it's a risk to address that
what we mean in terms of
king of all controls as a local
government for serving the dinosaur age
before computers and I had to work out
all the ratios between everything
expenditures our engineers and surveyors
scoop for everything they did the
results done on paper given its because
it is marginal convenient system and
will track of what this floor as me yes
value looks like in the systems we have
narrowed replenish track constantly so
that anyone we owned a life system we
can see exactly where someone who put it
there and follow right return empty we
all know no expressive government area
specifically state that should do it
mattered was UN council estate with
writing my appendix with like title will
there as it's a limited liability phone
company which is owned by Spears
slightly separate will that always will
who we've always be plagued the audience
on that or they eventually take over
their own eldest or will they give it a
source of my play buildings come on a
chair and green gangway training will
pay for any audience of their own and
the directors of the company said it
wasn't necessary for the first four
months of training given it wasn't even
half a year's training but I would think
for the next full financial year that
they will ever and all day and that they
will be covering their own costs ok
cancel instantly just keep us around
eight work 17 please what the ecstasy
was used for extra five thousand pounds
a lovely home quickly you can justify we
had quite a bit to the farm wife lighten
up over and that goes as well he hit bit
ly yes the feed in terms of what the x3
comprised of it was we set that up in
all the result report from John sex
under and and the key elements of it
included the extra work around the value
for the money conclusion that we did
last year in terms of insulin audit
where we have a quality of
qualifications are by family work so
there was some elements in that in turn
cause extra extra work the second
elements of it at least what these were
itemize into three separate songs I
could you sleep a purple robe to
consider a nun in that enough element
the second element consisted of and
there was some delays in working papers
coming to us and so when we try to to
conduct the audit we couldn't above the
word because delayed in working
basically coming and tourism and then
getting the information back which
extended Lee audit society and the third
element was to do with the Technion be
there was a technical issues regarding
and 400,000 pounds in the leg up how
that flows through the accounts and we
have we have to call in that case expert
advise to help us run financial
technical team
to help us resolve that issue according
I haven't advice and the extra work by
involved as part was the main part of
the reason for the extra fees hey
further question can I just come back on
one of the answers that was given by an
met regarding already sort of the let go
will given the fact would that big part
of the value of money only work that the
XO accountants do because I'd beer as
concerned that the let co thinks it
needs to do and I know it's up to the
directors consider whether or not they
do need thought it might be quite as
only they think they do need an audit
considering the size of it and the fact
if external accountants are producing
accounts for them ultimately then they
have a responsibility on producing their
report to say that the accounts are true
and fair I think it may be overkill and
I wonder if that's something that would
be looked at by the external auditors
you leave and I think me well if the
first issue is is that obviously figured
to be crippled counts a lot and how they
feature in the accountant at the moment
cassette at the Volk issue will be used
when we went back home we calculate
consolidate since the approach from
District Council's accounts and what
element that that will be what stage
that will be we must the finest
department to look at that this year
here and then to see whether
Anton on that and I think the issue and
then is is whether the if the company
attic so imported some implementing in
which case it depends what what so they
want under which name it they fall under
in terms of the they all neighborhoods
companies act all for naught yeah I'm so
to my understanding you've always been
involved in the project seemed a lot of
green at work but the direct to the
three directors of green gateway trading
this year deemed it wasn't necessary
lots of my understanding House Counsel
supposed to said is that their decision
next year weather and all they won't be
required until they know the level of
turnover up as we go through the year in
that I guess I think we can probably
take quite important actually gets let's
get them to consider Ella
value-for-money bikin saturated money
wasted did an audit on what could be
quite small turnover but unfortunately
or fortunately I hope greeting gateway
really does take off maybe it would be
worthwhile auditing in the first year
and then see how we go from there so
it's all we can consider we need to sit
with Beverly one more another time I
think it leads to beacon City look for
your life but let me examine family base
appearances if it already provides value
or not and what it can provide value
that out but some that there can be very
expensive for a small business and not
had a lot of value and that will be no
doubt due to their decision and they
will cut all the sources again after the
dinner that form actually perspective
okay
so again this is their windows to yoga
yes can be noted notice that nine to
consider the proposed to 2017-18 of
japan which is presented to members for
their consideration and approval so i'm
jealous liam is related to be in time or
that destroys distinction between lee
actually exciting as previously
discussed though this is the internal
its proposal for the work to be carried
out during the asian teen 18 unduly
nationally entirely wallet in standards
internal eating required to produce a
pain and all it plan which is based on
risk and which leads proponents were to
the council's identified
risks to it's the degree of impedance
objectives so as you've seen in appendix
1 of that entail the claims was
considered under the settings under each
Court risk and in King Julien's to be on
particular business priority to rush to
open legs this plan image being approved
replies committed following to challenge
whether they believe it sufficiently
focus efficient in coverage to provide
them visually hearings as part of its
ongoing really as a reference and
specifically is part of its role to
approve the young gotten pregnant act
yet in some gear and women Camacho team
so question being will reclaim because
the liberal provide you with the
encyclopedia as a key source insurance
design cm11 statements you specified
audits within the prime were identified
the consultative interviews with autism
directors mounting baritones executive
director it's also has influenced five
and settings which in turn audit take of
a number of facets to establish the
relative importance of an activity of
the council for for for carbon frame
generally and those facets are set down
in paragraph 3.1 on the 9.2 so principal
include the financial significance of
the intervention that was really
activity how important indeed by the
public in terms of their satisfaction
but it's a key process as part of the
business
running of the council we've got an
eagle statue back in principle so they
set out there so it's a process where
it's been identified in key areas for
coverage and like I say its own its main
objective is to also provide that head
of internal audit with sufficient
evidence to come to a legal conclusion
at the end of the year 17 19 of the
operation of the council's governs
arrangement risk management arrangements
series of internal control so I believe
that this plan will provide that
sufficient evidence that a good thought
the headings I'm willing to come to
their own opinion and sewing for for it
for the audit committee to insert and
source of key assurance went into
position whether or not to approve the
end of enslaving art final count license
Haley personal sorry also final surprise
mmmm so you're not horrible questions I
just like time standing so we love
that's over and then maybe express some
concerns and on page nine point five
offered fightin nine techniques a solid
contract management contract that would
be reviewed in 1789 for services IT
support services vice manager increasing
the first three of those must be our
three biggest contracts I'm not for
street signal bf4 biggest on look surely
we be but the first three certainly are
at three biggest I'm just started
concerned that that's taking on rather a
lot if I notice review how in depth is
the review we looking to see if they're
well managed and if they're being
completely [ __ ] that's probably quite
a lot of work at least 21 and IT support
services were visually be a new contract
next year as well and also with Lego
services I think it's going to be four
years left on it then three years i
think twenty twenty or twenty twenty-one
that's easy i'll just be concerned about
it might be too much work okay that's
that's a good question
take on Gordon and scoping developer or
get we train desire to impress on
particular elements are the contract in
terms of what we doing the most
important contract clauses organizing
arrangements it can be a big dive or it
can be and questions main focus that
what the management no other an
assistant management arrangements and
what they're doing in Spanish the
contract and what comes across their
debt to give them insurance as opposed
to actually coming out internally to
coming to 10 million versions of their
evidence yet the combined Simon scoping
of the work and they can be in that it
can anonymize in the inning and I
believe we had got timing the class of
the source of setting in terms of the
number of staff values to cover up for
contracts what foods coming out of the
unit of contract management is here we
have the recommendations of the main
sequence range of the environment
services of Education which was for the
environment assess and manage contract
to develop almost a protocol on approach
this romantic America so they need to
say this is haloween assess that what
most important parts of those contracts
are for us to manage and therefore our
approach can beam has that protocol
being rolled across the white t-shirts
in principles and so that will be short
but it's not a shortcut in terms of
cutting corners of all the work but it's
the basis of which will get us to your
point of understanding
that contract is being well managed very
quickly because what we're asking
management in two ways to show as well
what are the significant risks to
believe in that contract and how do they
know that those are being managed to a
reasonable level so it's a question of
management rather for internal bits go
and do some in-depth studies so for
instance of like accents as whether to
actually go out onto the very sensitive
little control whether or not i loves
calls until you comply with until ones
in question acknowledge how to manage
with them so intimately we ensure we do
have the results become the assessment
and we can make that those comments very
active I won't be it's a good point in
terms of protons world it in terms of
managing expectations and being very
clearly assurance that you will get from
that it won't be a hugely in bed
confirmation all the clauses in the
contract to being complied with it will
be an assessment of being management
understand what the most important parts
of contracting or do they have
sufficient evidence to demonstrate to
ask quite quickly interesting third
party site just having known that the
resources got best focus and council
gets what it needs to do that but what
that taker the biggest focus on a
contract which might be nearing the end
of its life where it might be more
important if we want to as accounts
enforce main beam terms which would
uphold the integrity of buildings for
instance that we look at those must be
fat or closely than a contract here at
the beginning of its life and that's a
really good point and ask the questions
we've asked the manager in terms of what
you see as the risks when these contract
and contracts walk down any particular
risks that are
contract which is as moment like a
kitten so that's a question we are but
be informed by that somehow material and
had one we belong together and caballo
sauce Germany or the lil bibby says
throughout the year is the timing would
we be getting I don't expect each other
bills that this would be updated same to
bring us any points throughout the year
so each of the audit meetings LG evasion
assassin s be particularly was there
quite critical to earth being
financially self-sufficient if they see
that there's a risk anyways of risk in
those not being as hard as i could make
each one passing terrible at science in
terms of looking at them there there's 4
2016 one quarter be completed so
throughout the game you should see time
you really to the price of progress
reports very findings okay thank you
they've gone out by the time that one on
this isn't a question that's really
going so i just want the understanding
hell because also on 9.6 you'll be able
to becoming financially self-sufficient
under that cloak wants to or that which
is almost over robust government
oversight and performance management
coleco which i think is almost exactly
same as the external audit the schedule
effect that would presumably feed into
the external auditors to something
specially be happy to share that the
results of that work in
what we did it's clearly little external
auditors for their home between them is
clearly a risk for the him internally
that's why I need to come to them there
anything on that as well so yes there
will be a level of joints coverage of it
but we type know they'll be number work
to ensure that that flow of information
insurance and externally where there are
standards and operates in process is
allowed to can rely on the working
internally this completely regulator and
file efforts just jumping back again
tonight we're five securement crowing
work for i'm showing a cursor is about
procurement last year I think I and
other members of that concerns about a
procurement procedures and policies and
I'm just wondering why it's called 24
rather than call turbine is actually how
you're allocating people is that when is
it to be finished buckles for and if
that's when we had to bring the theme so
into to sit there and it's time towards
the latter part again and the reason
orders just be finalized and therefore
there's there's a number of actions of
the poet recommendations and training we
want to give them something that
services the opportunity to to implement
at times and there's quite a function
during our nothing to possible
the continuance itself to progression so
I think the way that a number of
activity line up it will be it makes
more sense practically for us come along
later in the year to them to make sure
we've got the view on whether the
previously identified improvement
actually likes being embedded
effectively kadapa slinky in Christ and
people can can take on an improvement
actually the recommendation but really
there evidence that it went its weight
is usually happiness for tuning in some
leader appearing to allow that man to
lead a mission spectral tactic okay I
think my question has been answered but
I mean it was given because it doesn't
think very heavily to item 11 on our
agenda tonight and really I was just
asking how far we've actually got along
with that but i think it altered
everything thank you thank you further
questions thank you so can we yourself
that the proposed 2017-18 all depends
mainly clothes there's really great
item 10 review of the council's
corporate risk management policy and
framework for 2017-18 and that's
considerably port of the section 151
office representing a review of proposed
update the capital risk management
policy framework and corporate risk
register 1718 thank you okay and so what
we have in front of you is a report into
two parts first of all we've seen risk
management policy framework I believe
this was worked on the correct by my
predecessor denise marie and it's pretty
much unchanged this year without to
propose any particular changes to that
what they started outlines how
responsive can help risk should be
recognized how it should be reporting
there should be managed and the various
roles and responsibilities we have as
offices and even mounted to members as
well and then it's got later on a bit
how the process works in terms of the
individual risk registers and project
logs how that feeds up into this
conceived of weird stuff and then also
the risk of that I'm presenting to you
today so from that first one to do the
policy in the program hasn't haven't
changed this year we can fill one
interval such word seems to be working
fairly well so I'll then move on to the
second part which is in the actual risk
register so if I can draw your attention
to the page 10.1 to keeping so what we
have here is now keep corporate risk
dashboard and as you can see it's got
our and now poor teen risks we've
actually added one this year and then on
the right hand side the impacts and then
things like the likelihood impact and
risk rating so I thought the framework
we have a very defined element how we
determine things I've likelihood and
impact so we can actually measure
properly this is not subjective this is
quite formulate call much to follow now
what I want to draw your attention to
initially is these at-risk number three
the serious food or health and safety
environment or other means
the council would be culpable for now as
you know there was been previous years
there's been issues with this particular
risk and it's been around the food
element of that around the food
inspections and there and then the
issues that happened there and you will
notate still high now i'm pleased SIU
one ways that the underlying element of
this the food part of it has now been
addressed and that has been rated as
good as a control to fairly good new
team in pledge minus ETA Louisa is
restructured setting to make this work
for the food element of it is now turns
groups so I'd love to have seen that to
move to a lower risk but unfortunately
is now we've also identified this year
we've got had some issues with some of
the health and safety of that site so
what happened was it throughout forget
the months right i think it was about
through the summer basically and we did
quite a bit a big quality on some of
their health and safety practices and it
k mother was quite a few poor control
should i say around some of the
corporate health and safety assessments
that were happening we now have a
full-time house in focusing personally
yeah which is coming and actually it's
that work that person coming in that set
of them is quite a few things here we
need to deal with so we are now so
officers and the organization are now
moving ahead with that to try and
address some of these issues starting
with at the moment is quite a big
training program being rolled out of the
next few months to all starts under the
leadership team and then moving down on
health and safety training to the
assessments done properly and how do we
really understand what's going on so in
terms of a rich the recent of time it
hadn't changed but if the food element
has got better but the health and safety
beer holidays got worse but i think
there's just having a focus i think this
was something that we am told it
committee did identify in previous them
previous meetings of now right we were
worried about the potential risks in
health and safety and health of this but
pleased to hear you say that the food
side of things because that was a
considerable concern though this this
this growth down okay and creative
questions Carolingian oh I don't know
what you don't know is after the
teachers just incidentally also
obviously don't want i'd like to bring
your attention to denny's the final with
this 14 which of you which is the risk
on our ICT estar this is our new IT
system so as you know we are currently
going through a migration to a
cloud-based system i think it would be
completely inappropriate if we didn't
put it on here as a risk because it's
such a huge undertaking for us as an
organization in this day and age now
knows i see is the fact finder
everything we do get that wrong we're
going to be in trouble so for me whole
party this things being there is a risk
and this being honest and very very
carefully as you know we've got a
project team up and running we've got a
short description exactly you know our
to be sensible and indirect stories is
leading that project that shows the
emphasis on the importance of that
project and so he's keeping on what's
going on I'm getting ready to updates on
what's done with the project and I
believe members are being recently kept
abreast our house anyway and so here's
something we are absolutely keeping an
eye on and I think it's we're going to
will certainly keep on the wrist
register for the rest of this year and
Teal'c hopefully the migration happens
or between april and june and then we
can start to see that you know we've got
a new system placing a bris can actually
kiss people that's why i want to store
attention to is menopause
just goes well just point on risk-free
it works splitting it up into two
sections because of this two different
things game on here and I'm going to the
table what obstacles out of issues but
it's moved under the ultimate get
reflected on earth do not open if I
think it's not a bad point actually I
think we should do that I said on board
okay no other know me as a change the
recommendations with an injection yes
and that that would then identify that
the food risk is if you rose but I'd
rather do you want to we had of that
thank you for bringing a person amarian
common videos on risk number 10 which is
quite serious examples of never start at
the back of the document oh yeah that's
probably the highest risk having
attended the reason workshop around the
start survey also that speaking in terms
of resume in terms of actually being
tased when yet I guess just by your
thoughts really in terms of that still
seems to climb I'll be Leah's first but
I think that one and the one above it on
the ntfs will always be kind I think as
an organization of this size as rata
deeds and its location to London we do
struggle to keep to keep time you know
if we can't how long wages let's be
honest oh we're always going to struggle
against a it's always going to be a risk
obviously the best thing we can do is
join us or what other benefits we tend a
great working environment you know
plenty of opportunities things like that
the other side of it is you know that
the steps we've taken issue in terms of
we have increased the budget slider for
else passing as we recognize in 1780
know they've got to 300,000 founding
directly right there are areas under
extreme pressure at the moment so we're
trying to believe that perseverance
slightly that's going to help mitigate
some of this risk but again i'll be
honest i would always want to keep this
as high as high up on our agenda cuz i
think the minute we take our eye off the
ball on this will start to see the
people walking out the door or staff
morale drop in and then our efficiency
comes out the window
any further questions oh there's anyone
left on this one switch off on him page
10.13 safeguarding the firm with
referring to current risk is only a
sensible made of historic risk not
engage way come to life all right I
think that's a difficult question to
answer i think by me or we can do it
apart at the moment and savor the
controls we have in place now our goods
is there a risk that actually we're
going to have like to say historic
claims against us that's quite that's
potential all we can do is go back and
look at the the previous reviews of our
so calling controls go back to as far as
we can soon as dr. see if i wrote if we
thought there was a leak at the time or
whether we had any shortage I think it's
a difficulty much of answer because it's
a bit like how long is a piece of string
we just we done out beyond to you and
its own and they will say comes back to
things like a child policy and how HR
risk so if someone to that garden in the
same guys as if you think of a staff
member that may be left a few years ago
they could still be a claim you know we
think it's completely sector but it
never occurred actually that cannot be
something that we've never even aware so
I suppose it's for us to try and bounce
whether we think the risk is now when we
think our controls our now but still
potentially recognize they could restart
claims without trees we want no ID on
national incident given 14 the car
change what's happened in the past year
now and I think they probably ended up
really don't like the mouse yeah yeah
I'd certainly I think he's a question to
be asked if I actually do think we were
ever you know we had a bit of a
shortfall in any of these risks or
anything else previously we may now be
good but just to keep an eye on it so
that's a question we can ask so 10 20
clicks impacts of or Consequences one of
the other things you've got risky
an increasing complexity of compensation
claims resulting additional across and
inefficient use of resources what's the
trend on master moment are we
experiencing a lot of compensation
claims at all across the council far
fight definitely I don't think we are
not an issue that generally speaking we
interview like it's not so many six come
across it Oscar nom I submit have done
how about any what I've been here nearly
a year now so it's certainly not it's
nothing brings an excellent i'm probably
looking we're not seeing but you have a
column quality of control yes with an
extra card ok what does vs missed me now
you asking on financial check avenue
don't know what google completed with
tell you up and put you out there
so where I standards yeah that's all get
too much of all that I kind of do very
much we happy with it thank you for us
so it's supposed to be quickly resolved
the updated corporate risk management
policy and framework be approved and so
that the content of the corporate risk
register 2017-18 be noted including want
to come join us with the change to write
and frame it risk-free submitted
tutorial are we happy with that 11 to
consider the report of the assistant
director and democratic services which
girlfriend of attention two completely
different parents and provide an update
of all get recommendations thank you
dental treatment p.m. every committee we
bring a report summarizing in progress
and the outcome of the work completed in
portage a support and includes a names
like into the percentage of the audit
plan elite universities where we expect
theatre stage status in reference to
conversation
continuing simba my club ask about where
that the committee asked have some
indication of whether laying with plan
contractor delivered that said out honor
than one of frequent to where the figure
over where eighty-six percent to where
we'd expect to be to complete the work
and that the slippage the gap is
primarily due to the work undertaken
those that is unplanned is not included
in wings and we'll plan which one
corporate well they're preparing the
transporter and some regard to that are
investigating officer role which
supports investigations not fraud
investigation in this place but they can
be back with methods such as Daenerys
grievances et cetera so own weirdest
slightly off but in terms of confidence
and still ability to undertake and
complete sufficient work by the end of
say by the time of the June world
community has been confident that we
enough were completing to Michael that
had concern always have had sufficient
evidence on the place they're aliens and
that's likely outcome of God climb and
that's with the kiddies and
confidence-building really really plan a
theme delivered the I think it's
probably need so efficient so on a
little antsy it's a also an update on
pieces of work that are
going where the specific audience and
otherwise our party we planned in our
wild role and we'll set up throughout
the work that we're doing in relation to
developing an accountant counsel for
derangement Moskowitz and he remembers
also in discuss the previous meetings of
this committee I've insight through
assessments la paga against the summary
standards and the only good practice
guidance which and related to transport
arrangements in the local government the
appendix to also gives an update on
progress and counselors making a new
printing that the recommendations of
examples may include sports appendix 1
is probably where the bulk of to the
court in situated at this is the the
summaries of the work completed setting
their legal debt in you've given
victorian village wallet and some
background on why back and power buttons
has been reached in employment and the
scope of that water and that set an
attendance on front 11 for civil evans
and then we need to
thank you folks eleventyseven 3.6 I'm
expecting you to do specific year but
certainly will get a handle on financial
implications of these type of things
planted that cross the counter so far
that particular action as don't want to
speculate I don't think that's being put
into our defenses yet probably and
calculated after the event in terms and
by virtue of saying how many staff that
you spin counseling that been taken
towards it into an audit we encounter
those because that's how we manage our
resources there are other teams have
been blocking the HR directors being
enormously but really not asleep are non
stadium so it's not something that I'm
really too in terms of waving hands but
it is this something that we will know
really do cooks the costs are you as you
put there is a specific item in quite a
different item I'm just sort of
wondering why age majored so much if
it's if it's going to be a major props
if they majored in this report because
it's taking up 12 and controls Tuesdays
and therefore those is one plans to be
expect on that and so I've had we've got
to take away from a kind of its work
look what in your plans to focus on this
there's more time to choosing cost index
for us it is for us because in a sense
if you eat too much like a sunk cost
we've prayed that because it's nothing
additional sort of things that wouldn't
be I'd like to say it's very government
there is cost of it because everybody
could have been doing something else is
blind about this but when I put enough
circuses I will just use focus all now
having being city on the planet
there is a directed by the link thanks
one month later saw the finding is
intended meaning the recording sound so
enjoy it does sound as though that
hasn't been adhered to yes that's the
community so that if the catch is it
where we found from from the works will
be keeping found the pledge tools work
in rains in places in the manner
required is in relation to buy the
timing begins when a new voice was
received except etcetera leads so there
was a mean that was one of the reverse
one of the recommendations at hand is
right okay so is that a management issue
or is it just a perceived proceed to
issue it sounds to me like the
management aren't actually following
through as a normal yeah it's the
recommendation that they're the greatest
direct direct into that we really must
make sure our own staff involved in
renting and buying goods and services
are very aware of the way it's done the
leasing done ran theories that the rates
purchase order for you you engage and
then recommendation was made also that
there is focused management oversight of
it is actually happening how to improve
if there are particular types of things
services or to go to cancel
and they fight us in and combinations of
carrots and sticks improve that wart on
them and 11-13 it's got on the endlessly
and a busy for debate place now same way
that business folks will reviewed last
year sometimes out eight which sorry
where I'm going second one yeah we've
got limited they're going to do oh and
yes that's the inherent risk against
which we look at so so it's not the
actual case better a possible job in the
left column that into the possible risk
and then by virtue of being limited
against their we say yes there is there
are some of them to say that the proxy
data item and completed which isn't
really why that should be because I was
under the impression that business rates
we have been completely last year so we
should have a very straight you can
program the voi the graduation obviously
database is up to date what's the
situation's here we identified some
properties which three home have been
used up to the VOA they've got the
moment that we have a several properties
which we have potential to rise building
on which wasn't there the up-to-date
very very rather than the big enjoyed it
so where abouts are we on that talking
to the recent rally officer quite well
advanced camp we had a situation where
we had a temporary visitor officer who
then had an operation which we're
talking about
months is plugging along do the
necessary 30 days maintenance we have
now employed at all times business right
officer the temporary business officer
he's now back in the income support to
the visitor 18 now that they're making
quite good progress and greens with
up-to-date absentee tools where we at
I've done nothing no thank you Congress
businesses burn the change of anger
calvin smith in pain our communities are
the figures for companies who slipping
the alien voice but has never had that
is annoying chain of these things builds
you doesn't relate back to the purchase
order for something I wrong with it
that's when these things get paid if
there's no cuts or devonian cause he's
not pipes president there's a good one
yeah domestic type it has to match to me
an invoice without daughter will be
queried back to the area which would've
come from we haven't quantified that
this year we're going to buy that there
was an issue and we decided this year
that finishes cleaning sorting canceled
i I'm be careful how artists questioned
in relation to your can't identify it in
the back bit relation to business rates
we have said califican amounts of income
trees not collected we the shores have
adequate recommendation one moderate I
can't see the recommendation in appendix
to I don't know if you could appoint me
to look online it relates to resume
there at all
if I can give a hypothetical section 151
officers should be aware of the
advantage for they've come there to ask
is that even an email regarding it knock
our table black what what we put in
place if say a someone may have a
limited company which they rent building
in the building's throne and the company
may go broke after nine months or not
paying business rates and the obviously
there's no way to get the money because
the company's never forgive the texting
traded like I cart so any more than that
i can say outside the meeting if anyone
wants teachers by now 10 to 15 one off
so we currently aware of what I'm
talking about and obviously I relation
to the loss of income and we otherwise
know how internal these are aware of any
situations that might be like that would
take may not be activation now and power
leg would sound like this is the right
place to be no we're making then the
answer point do months because of we
only lose on testing so we're not we're
about posing okay that's right okay
I mean anything further so a
recommendation resolves that includes
three types of this that the update on
delivered in 2016-17 denoted that noted
another site concluded the results and
completed audit engagements in the
appendix 1 be noted and three that the
updated stages of all get
recommendations in appendix to be
enacted and then real of those great
thank you and I think that the end of
tonight clinking thank you very much for
thank you very much anybody thank you
Greg and you think this is yours love
yes this is my loss thanks to the chair
and Vice Chair we love members who've
made it a little things on the community
in very constructive and challenging in
the right ways and you can imagine also
to the community services between
stereotype rings and my colleagues make
me already work possible actually the
business we go out and ask please please
people questions in their very impatient
I would like to put it on record as well
thank you for your chat your work and
your health and I'm sure it's made a a
great different that with this last year
so I'd like that song we recorded as
logic we'll go with that yes rid of them
and carry much so both meeting and I
took 40
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you